uh good evening once again members
um this is a special meeting an
extraordinary meeting of the Council on
the um 3rd of November
my name is councilor Boyce I'm chairman
of the council members we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded during each item please put up
your hand
to indicate if you wish to speak I want
to then invite you at the appropriate
time please note that the YouTube live
stream sound recording is dependent
on the correct use of the microphones
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a paid your paragraph
number when referring to agenda papers
and keep your contribution as clear and
concise as possible
um apologies for absence can you run
through them again please miss Casey
counselors
Brian veal
after Harrod councilor Fleming
counted Morley
councilor white and we picked up Council
please
and cancer and
Stevens are
yeah okay yeah I think I think councilor
you mentioned councilor Durham
yes thank you
um
um so councilor siddle just to just to
make it I I do believe that Council
Stevens has sent to apologies because
she sent her apologies for last night's
meeting so I had assume that she'd send
apologies for this meeting as well all
right thanks thank you
um agenda item three Declaration of
interests to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
registerable interest and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
A code of conduct for members members
are reminded that they are also required
to disclose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
throughout the meeting any Declarations
of Interest
on this
no then a gender item for more than
District local development plan review
on pages 30 to 70 to consider the report
of the director of strategy performance
and governance leader
thank you chairman
um obviously I think the report is quite
well-defined what this is about and it
is born out of the recommendation of
ovian scrutiny that came up at the last
council meeting chairman and um it's
about reviewing the methodology in terms
of the the local development plan and
you'll see the recommendations there are
quite clinical run Article 2 the report
before members is setting out the modern
District local development plan review
methodology and including appendix one
which is being sought to be noted and
that's a very long document then there's
little two that the council considers
its decision options a set out in
section seven of this report to assure
itself that the modern District local
development plan review methodology is
an appropriate lawful and procedural
basis from which to conduct the Malden
District local development plan review
the whole context is set out chairman
explaining how really there is a
structure to this and about the legal
status and and obviously we have to do
things a certain way procedural
methodology is totally complained
contained within the report and
explained chairman I would like to draw
members attention though when I can get
to it
um because it is a rather long report
there is under seven there are two
options there which I will highlight and
I can't find the page yet but I'm
getting there Jim yeah I'm coming down
if I'm it's just very slow on this
machine to scroll there are options on
page 14 7.1 option one chairman continue
with the ldp review methodology a member
engagement approach as summarized in
this report then option two amend the
ldp review methodology and or member
engagement approach to provide further
Assurance uh chairman if I could hand
over I think to Mr Dodson first I think
please he would like to come in and I
think um we're going to have a
presentation from officer later thank
you Mr Dodson thank you chairman
um members have asked for for a review
of the methodology of the local
development plan
and officers have put together the
detailed report and appendix that you
have in your papers
Mrs Altov shawland will also take you
through a presentation covering the key
points I should apologize at this point
that Mr Winslow who was due to be here
and present is unwell and has been
unable to attend but will ably be
substituted by by Mrs old of Shoreland
it's my hope that the papers and the
presentation will help to clarify the
process and members understanding of why
and how the methodology operates in this
way of the significant changes to
National policy since the development of
the current plan
and have the evidence base that supports
the plan has changed in the eight years
since the work was undertaken for the
current plan
I hope that the report
and the presentation that you'll receive
offers the understanding and reassurance
to members for the ldp process to
progress
I would note that further delays to the
progression of the review do put the
district at further risk in terms of
both unallocated development and the
ability of the council to ensure a
provision of appropriate infrastructure
associated with the development is
brought forward
foreign
s for members to seek amendments to the
methodology
and whilst I hope this is not the case
once you've heard the advice of officers
we may depending on any proposals coming
forward need to adjourn Council for
legal advice and report back at a later
date on whether those proposals are
possible
I would also like to state that the
debate should focus solely on the
methodology
and not any individual sites that
members are concerned with this is about
how we review the plan not the
individual sites
but I now hand over to Mrs ulten through
you chairman yeah thank you Mr Dodson uh
Mr Shoreland would you like to give your
presentation please
stop working
smoking
can you say that yes
it's um it's not it's not sharing
properly but if you can see it that's
okay
so um
on the 17th of July of this year the
approved lgp became five years old
and there for irrespective of any
decision that we've made previously
um we now have a legal requirement to
review our plan that means at a minimum
a partial review is required at a
minimum of the Strategic policies in the
plan we have a legal
we have to do that legally
um
the MTP review has to be carried out in
accordance with the law and national
planning policy guidance and have regard
to National planning policy and we've
set to have a paragraphs 5.2 5.3 of the
report the various legal Provisions that
you you need to comply with in order to
make sure your methodology is legally
compliant policy compliant
so paragraph 5.6 of the report are the
basic steps which we need to complete in
order to make sure we're legally in
policy compliant so we need to prepare
our plan
so in the preparation stage we would set
out a timetable we'd up to date our
statement Community involvement would
set out a project plan and set a budget
set up procurement strategy approve the
duty took offer rate strategy and we've
we've done all we've done all of that
um so we've we've passed that phase of
the cloud preparation you would then
move on to initial evidence Gathering
and consultation so you would start to
update any of your relevant evidence you
would start to engage with your duty to
cooperate Partners you would produce an
issues and options document and carry
out a consultation exercise on that
document we would then refine the
spatial options the growth options apply
evidence to those remaking options
carrier or a commission additional
evidence such as transport modeling you
could engage with other partners such as
agile water
electricity companies you know other
people have an interest in where once
again we would engage with our duty to
cooperate Partners we would revise our
policies and draft them and we would
work on potential site allocations
we've reached the issue issues and
options stage so we consulted on our
resist options but we haven't got any
further than that so after that a
publication of an housing change people
to the next stage we would produce a
preferred options Rapport which would be
publicly consulted on
we would then analyze those consultation
responses and amends the draft plan and
then we would move on to the next stage
of the process and we would publish
um a draw a submission plan for our
examination
that would go after consultation so at
that point you are publishing your plan
and you can't change your plan on to
that point except to do typo changes
then you submit your plan to the
Secretary of State for examination and
you go into your examination period
um the inspector with someone to your
plan and foreign
he may want to do some modification
consultations
and after his examiner he produces a
report and if it's found sound then the
council
um go forward an adult book plan
so we have been following the
methodology for the local plan to set
out by the local government Association
planning advisory surface which is on
paragraph
5.7 for the report
I'll just put it on the slide but we we
are here in this in the process here so
we're developing our emerging local plan
so apart from the legal requirement uh
to review your lgp strategic policies
there are other reasons to carry on the
plan
um our plan is
um now moving out of date the mppf has
been updated three times since we
approved our plan in 2017 and the way
you set out your plan now differs from
the way that it was set out when we
submitted our plan of our approved plan
for examination now you have to have
separate strategic policies and they set
out your cross pamphlet issues and set
the Strategic direction of of an area
the present plan doesn't make a lot of
separation between strategic policies
and non-strategic policies so we're
going to have to unpick that and
effectively that means that nearly
border policies will require some some
form of attention
when you review your plan the housing
requirement rolls forward into your
refreshed plan period and that means
you're going to have to look at new site
applications both for housing and
possibly for economic sites to make sure
you have a consistent Supply in line
with your identified men
and local clients should be underpinned
by other state evidence and the evidence
base for present healthy pay is is quite
old in many respects some of the very
old and you know it's age practices in
town and that that all does need to be
updated
remember engagement for the lgp
um in February last year the parents are
established the planning policy working
Group of Seven members reporting into
the strategy and resources committee
on the 14th of March that working group
was opened up to me by all members to
meetings and that has been happening
when the meetings have been taking place
and the working group is going to be
working through the process of
formulating the plan and Reporting back
to strategy and resources committee and
ultimately Council
conference for the um working group are
to provide cross cross-county memory
engagement and discussion of the work
that prepare the policy documents for
reviewing and to provide informal
feedback and discussion with officers in
order to guide the formal
recommendations for strategy resources
committee
to provide regular updates
and to take part in um actually partying
and any planning policy training and
that that includes all the all members
now
so on the 6th of September the working
group accepted some proposed changes to
do better deliver its terms of reference
I tried to make sure that the working
group really focused on effectively
engaging in the process because going
forward it's going to have a really
enormous workload something to make sure
that it's really focused
so a forward plan was to be prepared and
aligned for the working group so that
everybody knows what's coming up on the
informed teachings
and it also allows members to engage at
appropriate times
agenda papers must be sent to members a
week in advance to ensure that members
are going to have time to read the
material because
though we have quite we have quite short
reports coming up in the future you know
they're going to be they could be
enormous reports for members to read
um the working group needs to focus on
strategic matters so we're not able to
cover specific broad matters so Awards
and forward you directly to what
officers to answer questions and they'll
be you know the the artists have been
responsive directly to individual board
members
and questions concerning the agenda of
the working group if there are other
questions if they're forwarding it in
advance to everybody then we can answer
them in advance and then that leaves us
time to focus on the key issues during
the meeting rather than be distracted by
answering things that we could have
sorted out ahead of time
so the recommendations of the paper set
out in section seven so for option one
continue with the ldp review methodology
and member engagement are summarized
um amend the ldp methodology and or
member engagement to provide further
assurance
thank you
um
yeah councilor fluka oh yeah thanks
Kevin I just a little bit confused
because we've we've actually got
recommendations on on the on the front
page of the report which which is the
normal place to see them but we keep
getting referred back to options on page
14. so are we to are we to uh accept one
and not the other or I I'm sorry I lost
really I'm I'm assuming I'll ask the
leader to to answer or uh uh Mr Dodson
but I'm I'm assuming that we're working
to the recommendations under under two
uh little one and little two and and a
leader thank you Tim yeah I've put the
recommendations on the order paper the
report be noted and the second one is to
give the Assurance to members really
about methodology the options were in
there
um because that really is summarizing if
we have that Assurance then obviously
the local plan review is going to
continue
with that methodology with member
engagement approach is summarized within
the report and the other option chairman
is about if it was to be amended the
local um the ldp methodology and or
memory engagement approached Brands
that's what's on the table but really
the report hopefully does give that
Assurance to members about the
methodology that has been applied so far
I think the report explains very well
about whether you do partial or a full
review it explains all the details
regarding that the legal process and
other things you have to meet regarding
the requirements that are laid out and
if you don't and how you can fulfill of
those I think for me when you look at
the report I think the things that very
important are the implications of if we
have a real great period of time where
we do not progress with this work
um actually having this pause in itself
um it is not ideal if I'm honest but it
was council's Will and that was what uh
greed and hence we've got the report
coming before members tonight but I do
place a warning there but the longer
that pause goes then we actually will
have taken longer period of time to
complete this review and it will create
uncertainty for our communities for
residents for businesses and everyone
and it will actually not give them
confidence so much probably in the
planning system and I do just air
members to consider all the implications
which are highly detailed within the
report and I consider chairman that the
report does actually give the assurances
and to why we're the methodology that's
being implied I was very pleased to see
that we are largely
um although it wasn't there when we
started our review with the Paz root
master and the toolkit that's provided I
know other authorities that have done it
but of course we started our review very
early on back in February 2021 with this
Council agreed to do that and under
local development scheme however we you
can see from the diagram within the
report clearly where we are in that in
that process but I would urge Council to
really consider this report see that it
does provide the assurances members seek
and I really think we do need to press
on with our local development plan
review chairman thank you very much
um yeah thank you German
um I actually would suggest that um you
said the impact on customers is high I
think it's no higher than what the
present situation we're in by the way
that it's already been managed so far I
don't think I think we've exposed
ourselves by not having a five-year land
Supply by not but the help the ldp not
being managed over the past few years
um and and actually taken account and
monitoring we had a fact that when it
went to appeal we had a 2.92 I think
it's 2.90 years land Supply when it went
to a huge appeal which cost this Council
substantial amount of money and we
actually proved that that figure was
incorrect I actually have some issues in
how the figures are actually being
calculated sometimes we think they've
been included other times they're not
being included that's where I actually
would like a greater understanding I
think I do have a fairly good
understanding of what actually happens
on the ldp anyway but I don't see how it
can actually make our situation worse so
I do not agree with you on that I think
the release of the Healer councilor stem
I'm advised that you're going into
details which isn't what we're we're on
about so if you could Round Up
chairman how can we not go into detail
do we just actually say I agree with it
I don't agree with it chairman
yeah cancer uh Mr Dodson uh you can come
back in a minute uh come to the stand
let's have Mr dodson's View
members asked separately for a review of
The Five-Year housing land Supply and
the the methodology through which that
that is
um developed those workshops are now
happening through a separate process the
item tonight is around the methodology
for the review of the ldp so it's a
separate issue and that's exactly what
the presentation was on today is how we
undertake this review The Five-Year
housing land Supply and any questions
around that and indeed how how it's been
managed through the the delivery of the
current plan is not what the question is
about that's been asked for this meeting
by members this meeting was asked to
review the methodology of the ODP review
which is what the report speaks to and
what the presentation
um covers thank you thank you thank you
Mr Council stamps noted but it actually
has been raised by the leader herself
just now about the level of risk which
was high
yeah I didn't raise that the leader
raised that chairman I actually
responded to what she what the leader
said okay okay I'm I'm not I'm not being
critical I'm just taking advice well uh
the leader says it's in the report yes I
was quoting him I was quoting from the
report on the implications I didn't go
into any further detail chair being
similar to a 30-month statutory review
period proposal put forward in a
government white paper
my question here is what the progress of
the proposed legislation outlined in
that white paper is in other words while
limiting the review to being similar to
the 30-month period may have seemed like
good practice given the constraints
placed by the pandemic such as as
meeting on meetings in person and the
presence of other new and strong
influences on work and socioeconomic
factors affecting policy changes as well
as the complexity of the issues facing
our rural district is time pressuring
the ldp review in this way still
appropriate yes there will be extra
budgetary considerations involved in
this but given that the ldp review is so
Central to shaping the present and
future of our district is the apparent
extent of the rush Justified and would a
review of time frames really bring on
board greater risk
I cannot see how we could possibly
undermine the confidence of the
community currently has in the planning
system much more than it is currently
undermined simply by taking a little
more time over the ldp review
furthermore our weaknesses in the
current our weaknesses in the current um
plan sorry our Witnesses in the current
plan really undermining its
defensibility in planning decisions
right now our current five year housing
loan Supply surely does that anyway the
main issue as far as I can see appendix
one makes such a persuasive argument for
wholesale policy review and actually and
I'd like to commend you on that report
because it made it a lot clearer to me
so thank you that a single question
comes to mind why has there been so
little obvious consultation up till now
with members on those policy revisions
so far and if anyone thinks they haven't
happened so far appendix one actually
contradicts that because to me that is a
tremendously huge body of work that I
knew nothing about until we got this
report given the importance in the whole
report placed upon both the necessity of
this task and the time frame plus the
advice at where we currently are in the
ldp review process is it not
extraordinarily that it's extraordinary
that at 6.5 in the a report we have a
table showing the work so far of the
planning policy working group which
includes four months where it was
canceled due to lack of business and
where I am struggling to spot any real
consultation on the content of the plan
of the policies being revised I
understand what Ann said at the end
there that we have now revised the terms
of reference of that working group but
how long have we got left I would say
not long enough thank you councilor
Lagan
I think it can suspense he's probably
saved me for about 20 minutes worth of
um
there's a difference between asking
questions and and debating yeah this is
not questions it's perhaps Timeless but
debate in three minutes well yeah thank
you chair and I'll have to speak quickly
coming near the end then because it is
um and thank you for the report it is it
helps produce Clarity
um we took we look at the um methodology
that methodology means the way of
achieving things and we have a framework
which is clearly outlined in here to
cover legal and policy compliant
structures the problem that I I have
Council expenses also picked up is about
4.3 and we're working on a planning
white paper it's only white paper I
don't think that's been bought the
Bill's been brought forward so the time
I would be really careful about is
trying to rush this thing through
um 0.5 on procedural methodology I agree
with that
um but the the meat inside the bones is
down to council so what council of this
size needs to go into that plan as long
as it meets the all legal Frameworks and
it's policy compliant is important and
we haven't had the the engagement that
we need to have
there's a couple of things
um I'm gonna I'm gonna color a lot of my
my points
um because cat suspenses said things
here
5.10.6 was on page nine it talks about
the the review of the plan
um and it talks about that the ldp the
the decision is whether the council
therefore has the freedom to conduct a
full or partial review of the ldps not
as flexible as it could be for some with
more recent uh plans etc etc but we
still say that we could choose how we
review our plan yeah because it is at
the end of the day our plan and the
conclusions at the end the impact on
customers
um little one
um if you read through that it talks the
longer the ldp's ports the longer it
will take for it to be reviewed which
could also undermine the confidence
local communities having the planning
system Etc I'll suggest that this has
already happened well this is why we're
having this conversation and we had the
officers do this work and given the
number of opposition groups that are
active and the call for sites exercise
and suggested changes to settlement
hierarchy key an unsettle scientific
methodology being used to access assess
rural infrastructure and I think the
little Earth three in that point was
also talks an impact of high
is the pause of the ldp cause an
uncertainty Etc and there's a bullet
point that talks about legal compliance
with the legislative framework and
National policy such as I'd like to see
some detail around that the way that can
be attached to the ldp 2029 the current
one
talks about the development management
and enforcement decisions making it to
continue to age and become out of
Conformity with national policy or law
again such as the ability to influence
proactively which parts of the district
this is really important can grow as a
part of a coordinate strategy
um and it says this is we'll have an
effect on the ability of the council to
influence planning for infrastructure
associative with growth that implies
officers policies determine where growth
is rather than a balanced view based on
residents desires and I think what what
I could go on for another hour but you
won't allow which here but I think that
one of the things that is really clear
is that we haven't had the member input
that we had we feel excluded therefore
the resonance feel excluded it's a bit
of a it's a bit of a this is destruction
this is the process that we have to
follow but we haven't had the ability to
influence that and it's the council's
local development plan not mine it's not
Mr dodson's it's the councils and it's
absolutely critical we get that right
going forward so I think that we should
look at another recommendation uh upon
the on the paper which is on page seven
and I think I'm probably going to get
um something chucked at me because
obviously these policies have been been
reviewed as Council Spencer says because
they've identified which strategic
policies and need this amount of work
I've had no input into any of that
um I think we should have full member
engagement workshops to provide input
and collaborative approach and
reflecting in the input of the members
to help shape the plan I think it's it's
a bold move but we need to have that we
need to get together we need to talk
about what we what we our desires are
get the views of the officer and the
legal teams to come back and said well
we can't do that because of XYZ what
infrastructure we need because if we
don't do that we're going to be excluded
so I think the methodology the framework
is great this has really helped but the
content and the Flesh on the bones we
need input
thank you um yeah I think I think
there's some uh issues there you you was
put in another recommendation
which can you can you say what that was
I can Indigo actually wrote that down uh
well that would be helpful help me
I reckon see it's we've got the option
so this is to go in under recommendation
too under the uh to make it a little
three yeah yeah we could we could well
it's actually option seven because
recommendation number oh hang on let me
go to the front page because this is why
Council fluke is quite right he said
it's a tad confusing
um yeah I'm not I'm I'm not trying to
change we can't change the officer's
report which is what you seem to be
doing oh no no no no recommendation that
that we've got in front of us yeah no
chair it says the the recommended little
two it says that the council consider
its decisions options are set out in
section seven of this report to assure
itself so those options in section seven
don't include which you could add on to
option two if you want you could say
Amendment I'm sorry
um I've I've got little two
recommendations that the council assures
itself that the modern District local
development plan review methodology is
an appropriate lawful and procedural
bases from which to conduct the modern
District local development plan review
that's recommendation too but then chair
you go back onto page 14. I'm sorry for
page 14. and section seven and it says
options because oh I'm I'm I'm sorry I'm
I'm looking at it wrong that's right
he's rather complicated uh a wrong
agenda
yeah okay you're right yeah sorry thank
you so sorry yeah it was really a thank
you chair because it's really important
we get this right for for future because
we need development we need it in the
right place and we need we need to be
involved in it we can we can either
members we can amend option two and say
I'm in the ldp review methodology and or
member engagement approach to provide
further assistance by having full member
engagement workshops to uh to provide
input and collaborate a collaborative
approach reflecting the input of members
to help shape the plan
so that then covers everything gives us
the opportunity to have those those
times and I won't accept the fact that
no we haven't got time because we have
and I am acutely aware of these things
right but there you go
Mr Dodson
yes thank you chairman I think that the
time time scale has already changed
um on this and um but I'd like to ask um
Mrs Holter of shortland to to clarify
some of the other issues and um some of
the points that have been raised as well
thank you
[Music]
so depending on the outcome of this uh
council meeting if we agree that we're
going to move on with the methodology
next week we will sit down and repeat
the timetable and re-clopt the timetable
to make sure that we can fit with the
working thing not within 30 months
because I don't think that's possible I
don't think that's possible now because
of the level of Engagement that members
want and the engagement with members is
none of the policies have been reviewed
yes they haven't done that work because
we're only at the stage of issues and
options we have an ebook come back to
you with the responses on the issues and
options consultation yet we've got to do
that and the first big piece of work
that members got to do is refine the
seventh options that were in issues and
options refine them down to unless
another so that we can start
apply the evidence we could start
working with you we can start
commissioning transport modeling where
to start working with people like
handling water who won't work with us on
on all of those options there's too much
work
um
we can't do that and we can't even start
really drafting policies until you reach
the stage of refining spatial options
down so all the consultation
comes after so there's loads of
consultation with members I mean
absolutely let's notice a bit it's just
that we haven't got to that point yet in
the process this is why we wanted
the policy working group to really hone
down its work because you're fine as we
go through this process that you will be
asked to do an incredible amount of work
and it will take members an incredible
amount of time but we haven't got to
that point yet the appendix
at the appendix one is just us going
through the plan policy by policy
looking to see if it conforms to
National policy and coverage and looking
to send the evidence out of date so that
you have a clearer picture about how
much in conformity the present plan is
now that doesn't mean that when you go
and make decisions that the plan is the
starting point of your decisions but
it's just an information to show you how
inconformity or out of control to your
present plan is
it does help but it doesn't it doesn't
um meet the fundamental of Crux of the
matter of we don't I don't even know
where we are now and I I spend an awful
lot of time with it I don't know where
the call for sites is materialized
there's so much information that we
don't know what the sort of plan would
be and there will be oh sorry there will
be work that's been done
um so whilst I accept and understand
that
um I think it's a little bit
um
I need to think of respect for what I've
put in it um I think it's a bit of a
remiss to to say we haven't got to a
certain stage because we've got all of
this level of detail and I gather I can
get the policies you've reviewed the
policies against the mppf which is a
guidance and the relevant legislation
but from then from now we need to draw
that line and say the methodology which
I felt I feel very like members are
excluded apart from the working group
which is councilor Spencer didn't meet
all the time anyway with no business on
an ldp review plan that's that that
stuck out and was quite a shock
um I think we need to to do
what I'm recommending and members can
support it or not
um but I think we need we we as a
council we need to own this plan we need
to put the detail within the plan and
work within the methodology and be
involved at every step of the way so
that we can actually look at what's
needed going forward from a residence
perspective okay
um we'll we'll come back to
um Michelle and you wish to say
something
yes some of the work that's been done
already
um we have to be very careful that
members
um
don't predetermine
site allocation
so we have to make handful about
an illegal phrase
when we get get end result we can be
legally challenged yeah so you know if
if you
don't take this as expected to process
thank you
thank you chairman yes I I think this
use of the word methodology is being
cast too wide what we've got
um are issues of the the uh the review
process
um on the method methodology which um
says is laid down
um for us and content and questions
relating to
The Five-Year land Supply or the
assessed need and into my mind the
justification for what the housing
market areas are really matters of
content
going into the into the um review
process
um
and we are asked to um
validate or agree that the methodology
of the review
process is
um acceptable and conforms legally and
so on
um
and there are there are one or two basic
decisions which we need to be
um uh quite clear on two two basic
decisions I mean
to accept as
um
Assurance
um report quite clearly lays out that we
need to make a full review of the plan
and to to agree that that is the case
um and secondly there is a question
about the the time scale of the plan
um which um I think probably needs to be
decided
um fairly early on but the the rest and
this is what council Legend I think has
primarily been focusing on is
um did you remember engagement and
there's just there's certain areas where
um we do we haven't been involved and we
do need to be
um we want
to we need to have a detailed
explanation of the sites that are deemed
to be suitable or unsuitable and the
reasons why we're we're getting off the
subject well I mean that's that's the
sort of um engagement that we need
indeed right and and and
um be involved in this question of
reviewing the seven options and bringing
them down to three uh this is part of
the process and I don't see why that
can't progress I've certainly got a
sense that members are upset uh at the
lack of their perceived lack of
involvement to this stage
um yeah so I think chairman we need to
um
consider what we mean by methodology
when we use the word
um we're talking about the review
process that is essentially laid down
for us
um and not
how we go about implementing that so I
think we we note that the we know the
methodology and we
um uh confirm the second of the options
in
um Power seven
um
but uh in with the emphasis on the need
for engagement on on the key decisions
thank you councilor said
thank you chairman yeah in terms of the
method in terms of the method there's
nothing wrong with the method We are
following the correct method so we can
be assured as a council that the
officers and the council is following
the correct method and we're doing it
legally now the issue is and it's to me
it stems back to last year so last year
when we first started doing this we had
the opportunity because of the Bradwell
B power station not going ahead so
immediately the council thought oh this
is a great opportunity we can use these
officers and do a partial review of our
ldp now because of the speed that we
were going at that particular time
there wasn't the member engagement and
that's where the issue arises there
wasn't a member engagement there wasn't
enough member engagement now the Crux of
it for me was last year when the
settlement hierarchy spreadsheet were
sent out to all members
but not all members did it and that's
that's where the options things arises
from so I did remind lots of members in
the in the Empire you need to complete
this but it still didn't happen so you
can't take a horse to water as they say
so that's where the the issue arises
that perhaps you can take it well yeah
you know what I meant something along
those lines as I've had a long day
um so in terms of that to me is where
this issue arrives so we now
exactly it wasn't explained enough so
we've now made the changes to the
working group so that everybody is
involved which is the crucial thing and
what we've learned from this and the
thing that we need to change is we need
to ensure that members are involved are
are included as much as possible through
the discussions yeah we've put we've put
this on hold so the things that we want
to talk about we haven't talked about we
haven't narrowed down the sites we
haven't narrowed down the options we
haven't said you know you know in terms
of those things because we've paused it
but we've now yeah if we move it forward
we can do that all members can get
involved in it I think that's the
cruising the council lag is saying and
others are saying is we want to be
involved and that's great that officers
that members want to be involved in it
um so if we can continue with that and
that's I think the only thing we really
need to in change is to ensure that
wherever possible that everybody is
consulted and involved and it is open to
everybody and it's not adjust the
working group that means the working
groups has 31 people on it so be it yeah
and that's it and the other thing as
well is that members that have been here
longer than I have probably found that
the this process was different to last
time and I think that's again where some
of the concerns have come oh it's not
like it was well again the obviously the
method has probably changed since that
time so we do need to do it we need to
get on with it and but we need to make
sure everybody's involved and that all
members are happy and that's the only
tweak that we need to make I think okay
another another recommendation
regular seminars member seminars Council
Fluker thank you chairman I I I mean I
like the idea of the the horse
um chairman as far as this is concerned
chairman uh you know if if the ldp is a
racehorse and the council is a stable I
can't help feeling that it's bolted what
concerns me is what return because at
the moment with the lack of member
involvement I I fear it may be a donkey
chairman but chairman what concerns me
is something that Miss Shoreland just
said when she spoke about the
methodology and then she spoke about
refining options down
and I think chairman so I'm just
enjoying myself that the chairman is on
board with what I'm saying is refining
those options now now one of my
questions is and I may have missed it
but I can't actually find anywhere where
the the seven options were agreed by
Council and I have looked for that and I
can't see specifically where Council
voted to well okay well I give if if
they were then I give way but my concern
my overarching concern now is is that
we've gone for a call of sites and some
of those sites within those options the
the applicants have been written to and
been told that they're acceptable
subject to sustainability so we've
actually moved that whole auctioneering
process one to seven forward without any
input from Members now members haven't
had the opportunity to say we haven't
had an option ourselves to to score
those and say well look you know this is
what we prefer to do and this is why
it's so much different to the ODB last
time it's being led by the developers
we've seen what's happened at North
fanbridge we've got an application
coming forward
um which is part of one of these options
and and we now have we now have this
situation and please tell me I'm wrong
and I've mentioned it before whereby at
appeal we could we could have the
development management team objecting to
an application and the policy team
saying this is acceptable subject to
sustainability test and you may well not
your head in and say that's not true but
based on the letters that were sent out
or the email that was sent out that is
true if if these locations sustainable
and I can't help thinking that there
should have been
proper engagement over those options
before we went to the public
consultation because as once we did that
once we did that we went to the public
consultation then this is no longer the
members plan and I'm sure I'm not the
only body the person that thinks
actually
I've got the leader and
um and then Mr Dobson
foreign
with all due respect what I would like
to say is um I understand how members
feel about the engagement and yes this
is a different process to the previous
local plan and the member engagement
route there however the planning policy
working group I think was opened up
um certainly in March and obviously
there are certain members that do come
that haven't been appointed to the
policy planning working group and others
what other reason but that was certainly
opened up yes they could be I mean we've
had some Vision workshops when I say
have we have I'm talking about the
council now and councilor siddle has
actually chairman of strategy and
resources
um I recall the elements you're talking
about I'm pretty sure regarding the
hierarchy when we did those I think also
chairman of the planning policy or
perhaps Council of stilts was maybe all
the way through and that did actually go
through SNR and I think it was Council
but what happened was I can recollect
very well and shame counselor herd's not
here unfortunately due to how can I put
it this way disturbances that may have
occurred in the chamber it was delayed
and therefore
um it was debated by a couple of months
as I recall three so we had that delay
and um yes it certainly was a full a
very big report very full report on that
um and that was covering the issues and
options that's how we had to agree going
out to consultation the seven now we
haven't looked any more at the Susan
options because at the moment the
officers are drawing up all the
responses for members to consider and we
did last time actually
um then go out on preferred options and
that's the process that will engage at
the right time here and that is for
members to consider what options they
want to go with out those seven but it's
easy if you do narrow it down we did
that in the previous process but that
isn't for members to come into the
equation definitely that's a member
Mr Dodson
yes thank you chairman I will hand over
to Mrs old off shawland shortly to to
give some detailed responses on those
but I was going to say more or less a
lot of what the leader said that those
those options were and the hierarchy was
developed through through workshops and
the issues and options
um when it went to consultation was
approved to a consultation which
included those seven options and that
was approved by Council
so
I am
I wanted to make clear on that none of
those sites either
are selected they're subject to the
auctioneering and the options
being developed
and and selected through which will be
the process of selecting the sites but
I'll hand over through you chairman to
Mrs altar of Shoreland to explain in
more detail
from the point of clarity I think it
would be really really important if we
could see the email on acceptability and
sustainability if it was put up on the
screen what's been sent to the
applicants because that doesn't quite
align from what I think I just heard but
we can perhaps do that in a moment thank
you yeah well I think that we we can
sort that later perhaps
um uh Miss Shoreland
yeah it's a cool the Comfort site so the
Healer
every Council has to get into Automation
and it has to be monitored and reviewed
every year irrespective of whether your
site allocating or you're clearing your
plan every year you should be reviewing
that document you should be looking for
new sites and you should be updating
that document we haven't done that piece
of work since 2012 so it was one of the
things that we had to address so the
site the sites that come in that they
are given a broad assessment suitable or
not suitable now that can change as
evidence is then plant on top of the
size and each side success but if the
developers or the people people who
submitted the proposals were clearly
sent an in an email or a letter stating
it does not allocate their site and it
most certainly does not give those those
sites planning permission when we hone
down our options from seven to a much
smaller number
the sights that fall out of the options
that you have chosen they just sit in
the Healer they just sit there nothing
will ever happen to them again they're
just in that evidence piece of uh
document and what the Healer does it
very broadly tells us how much land
we've got that would potentially be
develop because we can't work out which
options are okay if we don't know if
we've got enough land in each option to
deliver what we need so it's all part of
a process and then what happens is we're
hone down the options to a smaller
number then we'll start applying
evidence to those options so we haven't
done any transport modeling Council yeah
because we need to reduce number of our
options once we start doing that work
and we start doing um things like
looking more in detail at Heritage the
wildlife site stuff will be coming back
in and we'll be applying that we're
having an updated strategic flood risk
assessment that needs to be applied to
the options that we choose that will
change the Dynamics of the sites that
sit within those options so the ones
that you see is suitable now and
unsuitable that can change radically
once we start applying the evidence and
modeling that we look at and that's
that's where members start getting
involved because you can't make a
decision until you have all of the
relevant information in order to make a
robust decision so we're not we're not
at that stage yet at all what we've done
is a piece of work that we should have
done probably every year from 2012 we
haven't done it so we've actually just
bought the council up to date
um that seems to be new information
councilor Thompson
Council stamp and councilor lag and I'll
come back to you briefly in a minute but
I want to start thinking about getting
some
uh issues on the table counselors
Thompson thank you chairman
um unfortunately we haven't got anyone
from DM here but and I'm really
following on from what Mrs salt off
Shoreland has just said but
the point is while we have no allocated
sides or no more allocated sites and one
we don't have a five-year housing land
Supply broadly speaking any site
anywhere only has to prove it's
sustainable to fulfill the Tilted
balance and gain planning permission so
call that sites in the call for site
we're in the same position as every
other site and I'm obviously more than
happy to be corrected by Mrs alts
offshore and if that's wrong
um I know why members want to be
involved sooner because they want to
look at the sites because their
residents want them to look at the sites
because residents by and large don't
like quite a lot of them I know I don't
like what a lot of the ones that have
come forward in the call for sites but
now is not the time not until we've
decided on the options
for growth thank you okay Council
councilor stamp uh briefly
chairman I've not got a lot to say I
think um I think cancer excuse me
contrary to what cancer fluke are always
there's a lot to say actually even in my
absence he speaks on my behalf chairman
when he's my permission I think you'll
find
um yes yeah
um and um cancer Swain actually has
summed it up I feel there's a bit of
discourse the members want to be
involved and I I feel as though there's
pushback from the officers whether um
where I can I knew you were going to
shake your head Mr Dodson but I think
there's a bit of a lack of understanding
not that we don't want to work together
it's just that we feel that some members
haven't been and I know for a fact on
that planning policy working group I
said from day one all the members should
be entitled to it and I think there's a
pushback because everybody said there'd
be far too many members um actually been
on the group and nothing would get done
which I understand that but I think it's
everybody in this Chambers has basically
said they want more information and be
able to work with it and I think people
can move along those lines chairman I
think we can get this summed up and we
can move on I think Council stand and
there's some sense in that
um I shouldn't get involved in in the
debate but it it seems to me the
consensus was that there was acceptance
of the methodology
as the present so we are where we are
now and we just need to move forward
from where we are now and uh the the
other issue that councilor siddle and
others have alluded to or or not alluded
to made very clear is the lack of member
involvement so surely if we can agree
will we move forward from where we are
now and we have more member involvement
uh um leader did you well actually you
know if I forgot cancer lagging you said
I think yeah okay councilor Lagan thank
you I'll be quite succinct I just cancer
Thompson it's not correct he can build
anywhere as long as sustainability the
the plan still has uh our current ldp
still has weight and a poor course the
mppf and the presumption until applies
um you've sit there now on the head I
think of The Proposal that I made the
amendment to the recommendation is clear
that sums up what all members have said
and shared exactly what you've just said
um and I think and it calls me councilor
fluke is 100 right in what he says
um I would like to see the email
very much I think I think I saw a a
message to say that that could be put up
on the screen yeah that'd be really I'll
just I'll just conclude now chair
because I don't wanna I don't want to go
over old ground I think that we we do
need I think we need people in the room
together and I think we need to sit
there and be
um more of a workshop and then get to
the stage where this is what's going to
happen these are our options that we can
have and we've got enough skill at the
front and with our officers to be able
to give us those options
um because in closing in our in the
report five point four says compliance
with these legislative and policy crimes
is imperative in the ldp we all
understand that review to be found
legally compliant the sounds of the
future examination in public and reduce
the risk of successful judicial review
we know that we're not Daft we want to
make sure it is sound we want to reduce
the risk of the council but we've got to
be able to put stuff forward and have a
challenging way of thinking about it to
say this is this can stand up it might
not be how we did it in the past but we
can do it now and it would stand a very
very good chance as the inspector is
going to look at things reasonably chair
isn't he so we we need we need to to do
that
um
chairman um point of personal Clarity
right that is not what I said I was
badly misquoted and I was more than
happy to be corrected by any of the
officers I mean planners are planners
even if they do
um work in a slightly different
discipline they're all qualified
planners in the same way and all I said
was sites that have come forward in the
call for sites don't have an advantage
over any other site because they've
still got to produce their
sustainability they've still got to
evidence their sustainability right
thank you I object very strongly to
being miscredible yeah I'll tell you
what I'll do uh what because I I think
I'm a man I'm not gonna have an argument
what I do is we'll go back to the tape
if I'm incorrect then I'll send a formal
apology if I'm not I'll stand by it
um councilor spencerley briefly yes I
was just going to suggest that backing
up councilor lagann's idea about
workshops that and more workshops and
that we have them in person or at least
an option to be in person I understand
that some of the officers would have to
join us remotely and that's fine but I
just think that having meetings in
person is much more productive as I
think a lot of us have already seen in
the last couple of weeks with the
five-year housing land Supply workshops
it's just a working group it makes a lot
a lot of difference that's what I wanted
to say to make it positive and take it
forward thank you leader
I think the the sticking point that
appears to be is the member engagement
and a desire to have much more of that
I I think the assurances might be there
with the methodology and I appreciate
what council's Australian said about the
methodology but um if if to amend the
methodology then you're tweeting with
some of the legalities and that might
not be a possibility so I think what
members are saying uh go with uh the ldp
review methodology moving forward but
much more member engagement and wider
than just the planning policy working
group being um opened up but it will
mean briefings and it will mean member
seminars because members have stated and
made it quite clear they're feeling a
bit disenfranchised at the moment and I
do believe we can achieve that and I
would rely on councilor stilts as a
planning policy working group chairman
to be involved in that and of course all
members but I'm I feel there is room uh
to reach an agreement here on moving
forward but with obviously the
clarification that much more member
engagement is to be involved in the
appropriate way we did have working
groups remember seminars before and they
did work well it was all in the chamber
and um I I think that's the way forward
because I think not to do that would
probably result in something like
happening now if members do feel
disenfranchised so that would be my
proposal chairman on the table
I made a point that on option three on
seven on the options and made which has
been I'm not sure it's been seconded or
not I believe the councilor stamp did
seconds
are we coming away from what I thought
was a consensus now well chair no the
the yeah we said because we went with
option two and we just amended it didn't
we we said the option to amend the
little DP Review which I think covers
the flavor of everything
um to review methodology member
engagement or in the full memorization
workshops and and to provide input and
collaborative approach to reflecting the
input the members to help you
can can I see a written uh additional
um recommendation that you're
recommending could you could you write
it out for us please
uh right well lovely can you just um
pass it up here so we can see what we're
I can see what we're dealing with ice
approach
reflecting the input of the members yes
yeah um uh I've I've got a suggestion we
adjourn for a couple of minutes to try
and get this um sorted because I think
this um
uh
um Miss Casey I'm adjourning
thank you
uh members
um uh leader uh would you like to sum up
and we have a solution I believe uh well
yes chairman I think the summing up was
probably as it was before so I don't
know that I need to go over uh that
ground but what I would say and
obviously during the German I think
we've been able to make things um
clearer and um the intentions and so I
moved chairman recommendation little one
to note the report and then
recommendation nickel two option one of
page 14 7.1 but with the Assurance
enhanced sorry with the uh the insurance
enhanced member involvement through
workshops and seminars I think that was
largely uh what I um said sort of but
we've now got the defined wording
um through that purpose of when you join
the meeting chairman so I move that uh
thank you is that seconded thank you
um all those uh in agreement please show
that looks like it is unanimous
I thank you very much and close the
meeting at 21 15.